Brandon starts off this hour in
Greensboro North Carolina hey Brandon
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
hey Tom today better than I deserve sir
how can I help
yes sir me my wife learn some serious
debt and we got a baby on the way
towards the end of the year and I used
to get a lot of overtime but now that's
slowing it down so we're starting to see
the big picture how I'm on every dollar
calm I seem like we're hitting a
roadblock every time we start getting
towards a monster on this on state how
you can help count or you get no debt
tackle
okay what's your household income now
combined together we're looking at about
60,000 this year very good okay and and
you said you've got a hundred thousand
dollars in debt on what break it down
for me sure so we got on to credit cards
but is equal come on about four thousand
I've got two car loans those one bond is
about I would say about 65,000 Brenda
and break those apart for me sir we got
a a car loan 58,000 another car loan and
which is about 12,000 got a credit card
for value of a $50,000 car loan and a
$12,000 car loan yes sir that's right
all right only 58 is on what kind of car
it's a truck okay all right your truck
all right
and let's see what else we have a pretty
far which is about 500 a another
threshold about 3,500 in order to give
me 4,000 and credit cards yes sir is
this in addition to that no no that was
I was breaking it down oh I'm sorry
okay so 4,000 credit cards 58,000 on the
truck 12,000 on the car and what else
that's 65-74 I got student loans which
is about 14,500 and then got a a another
got a personal line for about 8,000
mm-hmm and then got a stole
like Lana credit for vowels about 300
bucks I must get that pay office so you
guys have been married eight years
I know we've actually only been married
about come on how long two years two
years mmm oh right yes sir
23 my lord you have made a mess fast
okay you had met a debt you didn't like
you've taken out that on everything yes
there yeah when I was young you know we
all do stupid things I'm trying to do
the debt snowball effect only things and
I just trying to get to pay down too
much possible but you know she's gonna
be out of work for about three months
and you know I'm just trying to figure
out you know what to do I don't want to
go past a due date on my bills on get
back credit or anything so I'll hear you
I hear you well the problem is this the
most expensive thing that you and I buy
that goes down in value is cars you will
not get ahead financially and I like
cars I got a nice truck right now so
that's it now you're in the driveway and
and but you will not get ahead if your
cars are more than the value of your
cars are more than half your annual
income you really can't you really will
struggle and yours are way your car the
total of your car debt is more than your
annual income so the biggest problem the
glaring thing that I see when I look at
this is your trucks got to go
it's insane absolutely insane in your
all situation now when you were getting
overtime how much overtime are you
getting to go with that 60,000 are we
getting on average about 20 hours of
hours and that would equate to how much
a year an income extra above the 60
about about $7,000 extra seven yes sir
okay yeah yeah so it still wasn't
working and then even yeah you just
bought a truck that's completely out of
control dude it's it is it's the atom
bomb in the middle of this mess as far
as I'm concerned looking at it and again
I'm not against you have a nice things I
don't get you nice things having you and
this thing owns your butt man
I mean you got a $700 truck payment
don't you yeah seven or payment and you
know I'm trying to meanwhile I was
trying to move out our part because
that's just taking up our budget too and
so we're trying to get something cheaper
yeah but you're always in your apartment
rent that's actually less partner in
snow eight ninety okay close tonight
yeah yeah so yeah but the apartments not
the problem the trucks a problem I mean
if you want to move out of the apartment
that's fine and if you want to sell her
car - that's fine get you two beaters I
don't care but this these things are
killing you I mean if you just had that
700 bucks back a month you would be able
to get the thing in balance that's what
that's what's that's what's getting you
here and then you don't have overtime
available to you now can you pick up a
second job then yeah um ice possibly do
so yeah now work eleven eight right now
but you know I'll do anything taste it
yeah to my family yeah no okay well I
want you to be there for your family but
your family right now is on the verge of
bankruptcy and because you guys have
bought everything in sight and put it on
credit cards so here's what I want you
to do I want you to go through Financial
Peace University which is a one-year
membership and you go to nine lessons
and a group in your area and then the
rest of it is it's all online but you
can take as much of an online as you
want to take but go to the group in the
area with your wife
and because you've got so many different
things you have to tear into here it's
so many different things that you have
to you have to turn around and if you
don't turn them around you're gonna
spend a decade getting out from under
this and you're gonna the more radical
you get and your changes the more
radical your results will be and so
that's what we want for you we want you
to turn this around so you don't have to
you know you don't have to have a new
baby coming of the world and you're so
stressed out you can't breathe and
trucks just not worth it you can get you
a truck later and pay cash for it after
you get yourself back squared around but
if you had no car payments right now
just that one thing you could blow
through the rest of this debt in no time
because of the
hundred seventy thousand is car debt and
you're 23 years old I mean somebody at
the car dealership was smoking crack to
give you this loan this loan should not
even been made
it's absurd so yeah it's got to go
it's absolutely gotta go and it's just
out of control
so anyway you hold on I'll have Kelly
pick up we will give you Financial Peace
University includes every dollar
subscription to the every dollar plus
for a year it's got all the bells and
whistles everything is about three four
hundred ollars where the stuff I'm
giving you to get get yourself turned
around here but when I was 27 years old
28 years old I went broke with a
brand-new baby and a toddler and I
remember how scared I was and if you're
not that scared you should be I want you
to get scared enough to do something
about this not so scared you get frozen
like a deer in the headlights but I want
you get scared enough to do something
about this so you hold on and we'll help
you we'll walk with you where you can
get through this but you got to do the
stuff we tell you to do there's no
negotiation on this dude trucks gone
hold on Kelly I'll pick up